Thanks, Sarah.
Now once again, everything I'll be doing in this lesson,
I can do completely offline.
I won't internet access to create a repository or add commits to it.
That's why I'm here at the forest again.
First, I'm going to create a Git repository.
I can either do this in an empty directory and create files later or
I can create the repository in a directory that already contains files.
Right now, I'm going to use an existing directory with some recipes.
I'll run ls dash a.
And I can see that there are three recipes here.
A cake recipe, a frosting recipe and a chili recipe.
Notice that there isn't a .git directory because this isn't a git
repository yet.
Now I'll run git init, which initializes or creates a new Git repository.
Now if I run ls dash a again,
I can see that the .git directory has been created.
How many commits do you think the new Git repository contains?
Enter your answer in this box.
And recall that commit is a snapshot out of a Git repository.
If you're not sure how many commits it will contain,
then just pick a number you think is reasonable.
Next, what command could you use to find out the answer to
the previous question?
Here's a hint.
This is a Git command that you learned last lesson.